[music]
>> I know many of my students and many
people have had many training programs.
Alhamdulillah, yet there are duas coming
out.
But if that kept the training program as
it is
and reached a level and then changed,
it's no problem.
I'm not saying this is the best.
I don't claim that there are no mistakes
in it.
There may be 10% mistakes. So, when you
change that 10% maybe the thing you have
changed is not the mistake, but it is
the pillar.
It is the foundation.
So, when we decided to have this program
we thought, "Okay, let's do something
which would be in the market for a
longer time."
And we decided, "Okay, let's go ahead."
Done. These are the dates. David came
back. So busy. Japan, what about Korea,
Dubai, Riyadh, Mecca, Jeddah, back here.
Okay, now what? Okay, maybe three four
days I'll plan and balance
four weeks I'll do preparation of the
notes.
When we started planning
we said, "Why not have a good thing?"
While achieving the best, we kept on
improvising, improvising.
For example, the stage.
The stage that we have is LED technology
which I just recently developed in the
past couple of years. It wasn't there
before.
And we realized Oscar uses this.
What does Oscar use? Okay, this.
What does guy mean? When you're doing
for Islam, do the what is THE BEST. WHY
SECOND best when you're doing for Allah?
So, we went out of the way to find the
best technology, the best cameras.
We'll discuss that on the seventh day,
inshallah.
And yes, no, yes, no, then we came on
this.
And you may not be aware yesterday
Sorry, day before yesterday, 15th.
The biggest show in Bollywood was there
on 15th of January called as the
Filmfare Award.
People who know
may not be seeing, but may know.
Correct? Many times you know things
which is bad, not that you like it.
The biggest Bollywood event
where most of the film stars come is
called as the Filmfare Award.
When we did our first conference, the
peace conference, we had a stage which
was bigger than the
Filmfare Award.
And we had the same directors, etc.
This time the Filmfare kept a ticket
because we're spending I don't know the
budget what they're spending. I'm told
about
maybe half a million dollar. I don't
know exactly what they're spending. More
than that, maybe.
So, to recover the money, they charged a
ticket.
For that 5-hour show they charged
Previously it was complimentary. Only to
selected few people like when you go to
Grammys, you can't buy the ticket. It is
only few maybe few hundred people
allowed.
A thousand people allowed. All
complimentary. This time they had a very
big stadium which is very close to where
we are in Worli.
The NSCI.
And has a capacity of more than 35,000
people. Indoor stadium.
It's very expensive.
Per day
hiring about 45 lakhs. That's somewhere
close to about
80,000
dollars
a day. They have to have for many days
that the
For your information
the person who did the stage
of the Filmfare, the same art director
is hired for this stage.
The person who did the lighting, the
same person did here.
The person who did the graphics, the
same person is doing here. The person
who's the DOP
DOP means director of photography. He's
the main key.
Same person.
The difference is they are doing for one
day.
That means they have to spend for about
three four days with trial.
We are doing for 45 days.
With the trial period more than 50 days.
Their stage is bigger, but our stage I
don't know how many LEDs they have put.
This is the latest technology.
It's very expensive.
You have to pay through your noses.
Done by Hollywood.
Now it's been done by Bollywood.
Why don't we use the best technology?
And I remember I don't reveal Yesterday
there was a participant saying, "Oh,
what is this stage? My eyes are
blinking. I'm getting a headache."
I told him that please don't create a
fitna. What's your problem? Please tell
me.
Do you think the people are fools in
Hollywood?
How can
you may have some problem.
And today when I was sitting, I realized
what was the problem.
The problem he was getting is not
because of the LED, it is because of
these lights.
The problem is when you see blood, you
say, "Oh, doctor is killing my
relative." You're not killing, you're
saving.
You should know where the problem is.
The director of photography tries to see
that because you are all speakers, he
wants each face to come correctly. So,
maybe he's put a little bit more light.
So, normally the actor tells, "Okay,
there's more light on my face. Please
reduce it." The matter is done. He
doesn't keep on claiming If he comes and
says, "I've got a heart attack." Why?
"No, I've got a pain in the chest." But
pain in the chest doesn't mean heart
attack.
So, the person has to be a doctor. "I
have a heart attack." Why? "I have a
heart attack." "No, I have a pain in the
chest." Pain in the chest doesn't mean
heart attack. Only it can be many
things.
So
a right patient tells his problems,
doesn't diagnose himself.
If I say I'm sitting and I'm getting a
headache, I don't know why.
Accept it. But telling the screen is not
right. It is all headache I'm getting
and you're creating a big fuss.
Creating a fitna.
I told him if you have a problem, tell
me.
But telling others Do you think Then
some of them said, "No, FINE." SOME OF
THEM SAID, "YES, YES, YES."
"EVEN I'm getting
because of the lights.
These are all
high quality."
Then I realized, "Okay, the problem is
the moment I said because I'm in the
field, I will tell the DOP to make it
less. I had no problem."
So, when you go to a doctor, don't
diagnose what you have.
Tell your symptom.
The doctor will realize what is your
problem.
"Give me injection." Why?
"No, no, I have a pain here." So, doctor
gives injection. That's placebo. It's
called placebo. Placebo means you give a
glucose injection. The patient wants
injection, give it to him. Let him go.
And he gets Doctor gets the money, but
it's a cure. That's called a placebo. We
when you treat a psychiatric patient
or a patient with a mental problem, you
give him what he wants. The job is done,
but that what he gave is useless.
No benefit, no loss. Glucose injection.
So, we are taught in the medical field,
"Injection there are too immature. Only
if you give me injection I'll be cured."
So, we give the patient injection.
Knowing very well injection will not
cure him, but he gets cured. Placebo.
So, when we decided when we're doing the
training program, why not have a
training program which will be in the
market for
a longer time.
So, we planned in such a way that
inshallah, inshallah, minimum it will be
for the next 50 years.
Inshallah.
So, that's how we came up with this. So,
we want to have the best. We didn't know
until a few days that we were going to
have this stage.
And even I'm speaking on such a stage
for the first time in my life.
No Muslim that I know of
in the world
have done such a stage. Yeah, they have
had LED screens, small ones. Old
technology. Even we had LEDs before.
But the different technology, P1, P2,
P3. Let's not go into the details. We'll
talk about it if time permits on day
seven.
So, that's the reason I say that when
you speak to an expert
take the best knowledge.
Don't try and be a hero that you know
this is right, that's right, that this
is correct, that's not correct.
If you have a problem, tell your problem
politely. Don't diagnose yourself.
You're not a doctor.
That means
we are fools.
Right?
If you are fools, why did you come here?
That means your research is wrong.
If you do research
class.
Once you have done, you have come
accept it
as long as it doesn't go against Quran
and Sunnah.
It may go against your logic, no
problem.
He's an expert, follow it.
If someone says something which is
against Quran and Sunnah, that's the
time you put your foot down because then
you will not get the master key, you
will not get the help of Allah which is
the most important.
Even if you find out, don't say, "Oh,
this is
Hey, why are you an expert? Are you a
scholar?
Even if you think it's against Quran and
Sunnah, it should be in a question form.
That
is it so allowed, not haram. I know last
time, oh Sheikh, what you are doing this
is haram. I said, which verse of the
Quran says that? Which Hadith says that?
No, no, so and so person said. Just
because so and so person said, does it
become haram?
So, there is an etiquette and manners
in how to address
people.
Especially when I come to training
course.
And one more thing,
I'll end this session with an example.
That when you take consultation from the
top people.
Who's in the consultancy field here?
Masha Allah. Have you heard the name of
McKinsey?
Heard the name McKinsey?
Yes, brother Atiq. Yes, I can the
McKinsey's
Netherlands headquarters is next to my
home. McKinsey's this? The headquarters
for the Netherlands is next to my home.
>> Now, because McKinsey's headquarters is
not in Netherlands, but McKinsey has
branches in many countries, including
Netherlands and including Bombay.
But, what's about McKinsey?
What is it?
They provide consultancy services, so
people come with different problems and
they have a team who does research and
they provide solution to them.
McKinsey, for your information, is
considered as one of the best
consultancy agencies.
And if you want to hire McKinsey,
you have to pay through your noses.
Then you have PricewaterhouseCoopers.
If you want to account in this KPMG,
we'll come into management field when we
do that.
The rule is that when you take
consultation from them,
all in million dollars or nothing less
than that.
And I had an opportunity to meet many of
these consultants. Take the consultant.
You know that I paid million dollar.
There are my friends who paid for them.
I consulted and they pay. There are fans
willing to pay for me, masha Allah.
And the charges are very high. What I
realize
at the end of the day,
what consultancy they give
is not worth what they're charging for.
So, one of my friends who's my fan,
said, "We want to hire them." I said,
"We have them."
Then we have a consultation.
After some time,
we also consulted with Parthenon.
Parthenon is one of the best for school
agencies. They are different fields.
Parthenon is known as one of the best in
the US based firm, having a
branch even in Bombay.
Parthenon.
And when we do consultancy,
we talk and we ask questions.
Then we realized
that many a times when I consult with
them, they'd say that never in our life
have you got a client like you.
The higher consultant you hire, you only
benefit if you can utilize them,
otherwise it's a waste of money.
You have to pay through your noses. If
you don't know how to utilize them, it
is nothing but israf. But if you know
how to utilize them, it is worth it.
So, many people hire these top firms
only for the name and image.
Fine, you have the money, you pay, you
get a stamp. By McKinsey, by Parthenon,
by KPMG, by PricewaterhouseCoopers. All
are the top firms.
But then we realized that if you can
really utilize them, the fees is there.
It is fixed.
You should know to utilize it, then it's
worth it, otherwise it's a waste of time
or only a label.
So, the higher consultant you go to,
it depends upon the client whether you
can
utilize that consultant or not.
They have their baggage to carry with.
If they charge anything.
And their baggage is very big.
>> [music]
[music]